foreign
new couple alert
that's Avril Lavigne and Tyga locking
lips what this is happening the two were
spotted getting cozy at the moogler by
Hunter Schaefer party during Paris
fashion week on Monday a month after the
skater boy singer and her former fiance
mod sun called off their engagement
shoot the icon so I'm just lucky to be
next to her well that was then and this
is now Tyga laying a big old kiss on
Avril with her arms wrapped around his
neck they were also photographed
laughing and leaving the party together
holding hands I got a lot of things to
be excited about and thankful for the
Allosaurus tells E.T that the hair is
having a lot of fun together
Mosaic in fashion and have mutual
friends so it's easy and nice they're
cute with each other and the attraction
between them is strong I'm excited to
like grow and go into a new Venture but
this isn't the first time Tyga and Avril
have been seen out together last month
they had dinner at Nobu in Malibu where
they hugged outside of the restaurant
and left in the same car just a few days
later reports surfaced that Avril and
mod Sun had called it quits when it
comes to relationships when it comes to
like anything in life if something is
not like
serving you or bringing you down or like
you know doesn't feel right or if
someone like mistreats you or it's like
something's like unfair it's like
move on like have a better life for
yourself and move forward a source at
the time told E.T that things hadn't
been great between them for a while and
after trying to make it work Avril
realized the relationship wasn't right
for her
the musician has yet to address the
split but mod broke his silence on
Instagram writing that in one week his
entire life completely changed I just
know there's a plan for it all I'll keep
my head up and always listen to my heart
even when it feels broken mod and Avril
got engaged in March 2022 in Paris my
girl is a straight princess
she's a straight princess so like you
know it's gonna be grandiose 100 Punk
Legends are going to be at this wedding
is what I want to know oh yeah he's
going to be a room full of it man it's
just gonna be a giant Mosh Pit the whole
night has Avril picked out a dress yet
no not yet the two dated for about a
year before he popped the question and
his album God save the teen features
several songs dedicated to her including
one titled Avril song she
is everything online
[Music]
well now it looks like Avril is giving
her kisses to Tyga and US fans are dying
for a collab
I'm with you
foreign